Hello Freak bitches.
Now they're judging everything you say.
You've had that before.
Yeah,
I drink it.
A lot of unknown bars
and you just start like,
well,
here's one of my stories.
One of my favorite doug stories is with
the fucking boxing match and Vegas,
and you were heckling and hold
him down and fuck his face.
It'll destroy his confidence.
This is the prelims,
prelims or this box listening audience.
You have to understand when you
go to whatever his boxing or UFC,
the undercard no one's there.
They're all out getting drinks awaiting,
waiting for the thing that they
don't understand to happen.
That's at the end.
So it's dead silent.
Bingo Hall Church.
Silence.
So you can heckle and from the back row.
But Joe Rogan good a second row,
so it's absolutely quiet
and we're in their heckling.
Let me take your fucking him in the ass.
No,
no,
no.
We'll take it because I wasn't heckling
at all because Douglas doesn't do
marijuana.
Joseph does marijuana.
Douglas does alcohol.
Joseph's freaking out because Douglas
Heckling ticket kind of fucking laugh.
You're the one who brought me in.
So I'm kind of your responsibility.
Yeah,
try making him come.
That always knocks me out like a light.
Wait till two seconds to go
and say you just got punked.
I don't remember that one.
It was a five fights in a
row with no one in the arena.
The boxers can hear you
well.
No,
no,
no.
He's being too too humble.
Here he got.
He started getting laughs
and that became a problem.
Became a problem.
One of them,
I don't.
I think it was holding
down and fuck his face.
That was the one that broke to waterfall.
The whole
break his confidence.
Let me say something about Doug Stam.
Hope will heckle a boxing when he.
He starts the right way.
It isn't just dive right
into the holding down.
Fuck his face.
He's.
He starts with some light jabs and then
he builds up and it gets more and more
bizarre and then it got to the
whole data and fuck his face.
But when he said,
hold him down and fuck his face,
I remember just hearing people go,
Oh shit
don can we showed up at some?
Don't remember the Don King Haeckel,
but don king showed up while you
can still hear of my uncles and uh,
what was the name of his movie?
Whatever,
in America,
only in America.
Can you,
can you,
uh,
yelled something only in America.
Can you fuck over you had so many,
but he was there and could
hear every word I said.
Um,
I did a thought experiment
a while back and I thought,
you know,
it's interesting because when I was,
when I was in college,
every one of my college
buddies know me as Arnold,
they don't even know me as mark.
They call me arnold because when we were
in college there was a TV show called
green acres and there was a pig
on the show called Arnold Ziff.
And I could eat more than anybody in,
in the,
in the college I went to
including the football team.
And so people would call me Arnold Ziff.
And so I became Ahrens,
Arnie Arnold for most of my life,
just because the amount of food,
just because the amount
of food I could eat.
And um,
did you have like contests
or is this just like,
but I just,
everybody knew it's like you're
going to eat that dessert,
you're going to eat those,
you're going to eat that steak,
you can have that.
Um,
but it was running 100 miles a week.
I was skinny fat.
I weighed 30 pounds less than I weigh now,
but I just,
the throughput was,
was where it was.
Um,
and because I had leaky gut,
probably a lot of it just
went right out the button,
the button.
So,
um,
uh,
the thought experiment was that my
whole life I sort of was guilty of this,
like how much food can I eat and not
gain weight and not be uncomfortable.
You know,
that's,
I think a lot of people look that way.
It's like,
all right,
we're going to go eat lunch.
How much food can I eat and uh,
and,
and not gain weight or how much of that
cake or that pie can eat or whatever.
People I think tend to this is,
this is the,
what can I get away with part of it?
Well,
what if we shifted that
around and you said,
what's the least amount of food I can
eat and maintain muscle mass and maintain
energy and and not get sick and most
importantly not be hungry and you find if
you do this experiment
is pretty interesting.
If you become good at burning fat,
your your appetite,
so self regulate and so mitigates that
you find yourself pushing a plate of food
away after a couple of bites or not being
hungry or eating just the right amount
of food to to to get you through the
day and a couple other people out.
They took a trip out to
Japan and I popped out there,
got out there January third.
I was hanging out with
this girl out there.
We'd go to this bar,
so nice bar in Japan
called Jbs jazz blues.
So also a lot of the bars out there,
the names of them in English
are very on the nose.
It's a hip hop club.
It's Club Harlem,
Shit like that.
Like,
Oh the club that plays.
So let's call it 70,
like shit,
like really on the nose.
So we go to jazz blues,
so if you haven't Tokyo check it out.
It's just,
it's a small bar.
Uh,
I don't know the owner's name,
but it's full of vinyl records
and you can just request.
He has all types of vital records
is in a lot of Japanese people.
They were Americans or it
was some Japanese people
but it was in Tokyo at this
bar in Tokyo.
In Tokyo is some but not an eoc a lot,
but the bar.
But the bar itself,
it only holds 10,
15.
It's a small spot.
Ten or 15 people if that.
Yeah.
Pack like 10,
15.
It'll be pants.
It's ruining something.
Yeah,
it's this room.
Maybe it's my smaller than this room.
Whoa.
So it's a nice little
bar.
They also had this area
called the Golden Guy,
which on is has a,
it's an area full of small bars that
only hold four or five people that are
smaller than this.
The smaller than that place,
like super small places.
So at this bar,
the guy just knows the collection is,
it's a wall full of vinyl
and then his son behind it,
behind the bar also.
So you was he,
he what you want to hear,
say a stew,
stevie wonder songs in the key of life
and he just walks right up to the spot.
I mean it's obviously Stevie,
but he just walks up to the,
a bunch of records.
He didn't even flipped
through it or nothing.
He just knew exactly what.
He just grabbed it,
put it on there.
So we're hanging out and it was just A.
I'm with the girl who was half Japanese,
half white,
but she knew Japanese and English
and she saw a friend there.
So they started talking to Japanese.
That's this white chick
there that's super drunk,
like blush on her eyes is all fucked up.
Weird.
Like she had that stereotypical
like central casting drunk.
You know what I mean?
Like she was going to an audition to be
a drunk lady right after she was at the
bar.
So they started talking in Japanese.
She talked to me a little bit.
I found out she lives in the
same neighborhood that I do.
Williamsburg,
Brooklyn.
She starts,
they started talking to Japanese.
She's like,
you know what they're saying?
I'm like,
Nah,
she just be in play.
And then she says,
is this your wife?
I said,
no,
that's not my wife said,
is that your wife said,
no,
stop my wife.
Snatch your wife.
I was like,
why'd you just ask me the same
thing three times in a row?
Because I just,
she just asked me.
I guess he was that faded dog.
Her face turns and she's just,
I could just see her getting upset.
She starts flipping out like,
fuck you,
you didn't have to be disrespectful.
No,
fuck him.
He thinks because he's
without Japanese girl.
He's well like started,
you know,
you don't go in,
you think you're some cool comedian.
So then it revealed
that she knew I didn't.
I didn't tell her who.
I didn't say my job or anything to us.
So she knew me.
She didn't show them.
So now she is in a different.
She's just super upset.
Fuck you.
You came all the way over here.
You're doing.
And then she just started getting ready.
She was like,
he's a monkey,
he's a monkey.
I'm like,
Yo,
this is.
Am I being called a monkey by a white
woman from Williamsburg in Tokyo right
now?
What the fuck is why you should take
pictures of her and put it up all around
Williamsburg.
I should I just send this dummy.
Have you seen?
I should have thought
about starting to fill.
But it was just so weird that she.
For Real,
all I did objectively,
I wasn't in their face.
So I'd have a.